we have one more speaker before there's
a break and then we have a team of
speakers coming at 7:30 7:30 thank you
okay
I'm Gavin laughs Ness I'm a professor of
architecture here at Carnegie Mellon
University focused on sustainability and
energy efficiency and climate change and
architecture and I have the privilege of
introducing the next speaker Don
Anderson I'm thrilled to be able to
introduce him very rarely will you hear
the words private equity and
sustainability come up in the same talk
so this is going to be an exciting topic
altogether Don Anderson has extremely
humble beginning because he's trained as
an architect he is from from his early
years he worked with both Bert Hill
Cosell riddle man for those who are over
a certain age in this room you may
remember Bert Hill as a Pittsburgh and
Butler PA based leading engineering and
architectural firm focused on energy
efficiency in buildings and Don was part
of the DC group of Bert Hill Kosova and
with Harry Gordon after running a firm
on his own he joined ICF for 15 years an
ICF with 5,000 employees worldwide it
does obviously transformative work in
the digital world and from there he
joined the Blackstone Group where he's
been for the last seven or eight years
which although it only has 2,300
employees worldwide actually as an
equity firm is owner of a portfolio with
well over almost 500 thousand employees
worldwide so it's a really critical body
of not only employees but of buildings
around the world that Don is being
transformative in he has the first
corporate sustainability officer
position for the Gladstone group and and
he he's a Blackstone I'm sorry whoa
sorry Donald kill me on this one
Blackstone Group and he's
been absolutely transformative in the
way in which he brings the issues of
sustainability and climate change and
energy into the executive boardroom he
is in addition to being a key member of
the Blackstone Group he is also on the
board of directors of the green building
certification Institute GBC I is the
organization behind the certification of
lead and and well and a whole series of
environmental standards that are
actually dramatically impacting the
portfolio's of buildings around the
world he's also on the board of
directors of ntek which is a Blackstone
investment that's focused on using and
leveraging the Internet of Things and
and cloud and machine learning and SAS
to actually transform the way in which
building automation systems are deployed
and building so he brings an incredible
in-depth expertise on building
portfolios and the impact they're having
on global sustainability and with that
I'm privileged to be able to introduce
Don Anderson
how are you doing good long day it's
good to be here it's good to get out of
New York City and it's good to talk to a
group of people that are involved in
energy efficiency
you're not investors in Blackstone I
don't think alright and I don't I don't
think we own any of you so you're not
our companies so that's this is really
good for me
I get to I get to hopefully not
misbehave too much what I did was I put
together some slides that I use with our
investors some I used last night with a
bunch of people from Merrill Lynch and
the slides I use with the companies that
we own and I have some simple slides
that I did that just are meant to convey
pretty much a shotgun blast of
everything that that matters to me in
terms of my career and stuff I wish I
knew decades ago and some stuff I
learned decades ago that I'm glad I
never forgot so I have a lot of material
I'm probably offend half of you and
that'll make for some good questions and
hopefully there'll be something here
that you've that you've that you haven't
thought about so first of all I don't
want to spend a lot of time on private
equity but but but basically what we do
is we buy companies we we spend several
years three years as a is a is a good
turn sequence when the economy is good
fixing up the company and then we IPR we
sell and so in part of an ops team that
includes other segments of improvement
I'm chief sustainability officer but
really I'm looking for energy cost
savings because it drops to the bottom
line is eBay da and then in real estate
it contributes to the asset value on
sale but but in terms of Blackstone I
think we're the biggest private equity
company and I think of interest to you
and me are our private equity holdings
things like Michaels store SeaWorld for
Saatchi Crocs and then our real estate
portfolio which includes the largest
portfolio of single-family homes in the
u.s. multifamily all over the world
malls
with logistics distribution centers
almost every sector and it's 200 billion
dollars worth of this stuff and that's
my that's my field of play there's
several thousand private equity firms
now in the world if you if you add it up
it's a massive chunk of the global
economy and some want to have ops groups
like Blackstone and sometimes it's a
bunch of McKinsey X McKinsey people but
but for Ops teams there's a ton of
pressure around what what we do and a
lot of proven upside so for those of you
I can see some of you are into your
careers and even dressed up for this
this event but but those of you that are
facing a career you you want to take a
look at this it's really unusual I'm the
first chief sustainability officer I I'm
an anomaly and I and I enjoy it I think
a key thing and the evolution of private
equity I'll just do this very quickly is
the is the ops factor and transforming
these companies so years ago you you
hear the phrase barbarians at the gate
we were accused of disassembling
companies over leveraging them and
destroying them so I I'm from Maryland
you know I came from far away to come to
Blackstone I haven't seen any of that I
think that was way before my time it
makes me happy I've got a five element
program and because you guys are in the
space I don't want to I don't want to go
too deep with you so I'm gonna run this
very quickly and I'll touch on some of
this as I go dashboards for me this is
spend visibility over time and I want to
normalize by productivity occupancy
sales it's it's a lot harder than you'd
think they get this set up scorecards
number two
I love scorecards I wish I had figured
them out when Ann and I worked at ICF
every row as a site every column and
every section of columns is a system
that you care about and the attributes
you want to track for that system so if
you are row if your site has too much
read you might lose your job so it's
it's culture in a box it's incredibly
effective for me fast fine and fix our
the word audit I've never let my team's
use the word on it fast finding fixes an
assessment that's kind of like a
workshop where you're kind of
socializing you're starting a
partnership because I've got three years
sometimes more with a company I have to
move very quickly I can't I can't come
in in a suit or bring in an engineer
that's going to do smartest smartest
person in the room stuff with my company
so fast finding fix is my way of kind of
crafting what what is called an audit
part of what happens during fast find
and fix is a toolkit gets gets
socialized and trained I'll talk more
about this transformational for me and
then finally Big Data Vivien mentioned
in tick we took up a piece of this
company that does remote analytics it
sits on top of the BAS system at a
portfolio level that's that's why I wish
I was 40 and not 61 because that that's
gonna be big for those you still have
some time left and this and this is just
a picture of the stuff that I try and
implement very quickly I use tonight or
electric they actually do a thing for me
where they will send an email out to
every site collect updated data for the
scorecard and then assemble a new
scorecard and they can do it for
hundreds of sites and they do it for me
for free that that's that's been great
for me so this is a disclaimer right
just just so you understand private
equity because the SEC watches us very
carefully it's gonna take me a few
minutes to go through this but I have to
I just have to run this down that's a
joke I'm glad you're starting to get my
jokes but wait wait there's a second
page right so in terms of the landscape
I live I live in right I have to dress
like this in New York City and we don't
wear button-down collars right I had to
go in the web and figure that out seven
years ago and there's a lot of care like
I know the general council office way
better than I ever thought I would but
somehow I've been on the home page at
Blackstone since September all right so
somebody will get fired for this
I'm the from the first person you see
and if you drill down there's a black
paper that somehow made it through
General Counsel and a couple videos of
podcast I'm
really proud of this as someone that's
come from your space to end up on the
homepage I'm so proud of this but it is
the demands of the investors that hammer
us that got me my job almost seven years
ago and that's the reason I'm on the
homepage I don't have any illusions
about this but I'm still proud of it so
so now let's let's just step step back
from all this and get more serious
Vivian was fooled she said I'm an
architect I'm a fake engineer I'm a fake
designer and I'm a fake software
developer I don't have any academic
qualifications to do that work and for
those of you that are in the middle of
your graduate or undergraduate program
and you're really worried about your
course load and which courses and which
degree it didn't matter to me it turned
out to be very unimportant but the fact
that I developed expertise around energy
allowed me to enter these spaces and
these were segments of my career that I
really enjoyed so I didn't have to be a
program and I don't want to be a
programmer and I don't have to know all
the nuts and bolts of engineering I just
have to have a bag of tricks that can be
coded in software that can be deployed
at a portfolio level and I'm a late
bloomer I was promoted in December of
last year to partner at Blackstone I
have to be the first sustainability
partner in private equity in the finance
world I'm 61 it's late I don't have a
lot of time but I'm proud of that too so
excuse me for being proud I want to do I
want to do a a level set if I can make
the technology work because because
we're we're all in this space and I
remember the gas lines in the early 70s
so we've all been at this for a very
long time and I think this is kind of an
echo chamber and everybody's very
knowledgeable and we bring our best
stories to the table we think
everything's everything's great and
better than it used to be to me it's not
it's not better than it used to be it's
as bad as ever if I get the mouse back
there we go this is a commercial
building example from my experience
watch the ceiling carefully
so they don't stay up forever
they spend some time down a down
position so that's important to note and
then here's an industrial example that I
discovered in the very deep bowels of a
factory it's a fluorescent fixture
fixture and you know I'm not gonna we
don't need to talk about why this is
happening although we could spend a lot
of time together but but when you go out
in the field sometimes you can see
problems but usually 99.9% of the time
the problems are this bad but there's
just no evidence all right so let me
just keep moving then another thing that
I think is really hurting us is language
and so the finance world has a whole set
of language that we're being pushed on
with by investors I don't use any of the
language in the red box all right I hate
it for what I have to do the speed at
which I have to transform a company I
don't want to bring any words to the
table that I have to define in front of
CEO CFO CEO Oh general manager to say
somebody in a mechanical room so the red
box is is I don't use it the green box
this language has been around since the
dawn of business I want to use this
language all the time
I'm pretty cranky on this so yes G how
many people know what E is G is not not
a majority good all right this is the
new umbrella term from the financial
world environment social governance so a
lot of times when I sit down with
investors they'll ask me if we hire
children I now say no we don't listen
are you sure you don't hire children I
really want to talk about outdoor air
dampers right and scheduling them
properly but I have to live under this
umbrella now the nice thing for you guys
is the e is really the only place where
there's money involved that's a key
thing for me I work at Blackstone so
there's a new crop of ESG consultants
and they come more out of the s and the
G they don't know how to do
transformation right and when you hear
them talk and I want you
listen carefully then with them I want
you to call them on this it's accounting
talk its disclosure transparency
footprinting all the things that are
completely different from transformation
I think that's either bad for us or good
for us depending on how we handle it so
scatter plots when we were doing the
Energy Star benchmarking tool the
portfolio manager tool we had access to
tons and tons of data I started to ask
for views that were that scatter plotted
energy energy spend or energy usage
across the portfolio so this is a
homogeneous retail portfolio in North
America there's around a 6x variation in
performance because it's clustered this
is not with LEDs without LEDs there's
something else going on here in this
case and it took a while to figure this
out
6,000 rooftop units were designed to
provide six hundred to a thousand
percent of the outdoor air that's
actually needed by these stores but
that's a huge issue and in some stores
the manager would say I can see the sky
through my my Inlet that's not supposed
to be so Snyder designed an app in their
resource advisor tool or you can mouse
over that red line and move it up or
down and it'll recalculate the savings
if all the laggards which is where I
want to spend my time are brought down
to the line and so for most portfolios
those of you that have the ability to
work in portfolios this is a view that
is shocking they no one's ever taken
this view before this is a view that got
me my black stone job because the guys
that already were in place and thought
they knew everything couldn't explain
this was great it's good times so that
cluster leads leads me to this concept
of low cost no cost that's my primary
interest and if I'm going after low cost
no cost I'm going after om that's that's
where I spend my time I know it's not
where all of you spend your time that's
where I spend my time the class of
studies energy started three studies I
really love two of these are available
online
they were AC Triple E papers by Tom
Hicks and
Vinita the punchline here for me
although there's a lot of information
here in the in the two papers is that
the presence of energy-efficient
technology does not correlate well to
whole building energy performance when I
first heard that in 1999 I I couldn't
believe it but I completely changed my
orientation you know career-wise so you
can get these and read them so for those
of us that are trying to transform we
don't have endless factors to deal with
this is this is pretty much it and for
me my favorites or kind of pressure and
timing but if I'm if I'm involved in a
pursuit and I don't hear this language
from the engineers I brought or that the
team that's on-site I know there's a
problem and sometimes it's just useful
to kind of come back to basics it's like
a Buddhist dorm of coming back to your
breathing look this is all we've got you
know and it's it's not that easy to make
all this stuff work together and and
this is what we're asked to preserve
right these are the things that we go
into a building and we and we care about
and if you're working in hospitality if
you don't cover the comfort issue right
up front you're not gonna get traction
because that's all they fear is it gonna
come in and you're gonna put comfort at
risk so you hit that right up right off
the back that industrial productivity is
key Safety's key growth for Blackstone
is key and money's key right none of
these have anything to do with energy
really right money is it utility bills
but you don't want to come into the
wrong about Anson talk about kwkw hkw
per tonne and then there's only a few
things in my experience that really work
at a portfolio level or if you want to
transform a site fast cadence calls PM's
in the industrial world these are
preventive maintenance tasks you either
do 100 percent or you're fail failing
scorecards you know I like scorecards
and then some kind of reward there's
plenty of other things but I like to
keep it keep it two bases so I like
quotes you know I always I always am
alert and I collect quotes when I go out
and I do work so this is my favorite
black stone Eric
first shift hates second shift so I was
in the middle of an assessment I had
engineers in we were gonna look at all
the systems somebody just whispered this
in my ear all right I can get on the
plane home I know everything I need to
know about the system which I'll talk
about the site and the company's
leadership right this happened to be an
ammonia refrigeration system in a
manufacturing site we would all use
ammonia in our homes except it's deadly
and these guys disagreed on how to run
that deadly system over a 24-hour period
and they these are these were old guys
like me that just weren't enough for a
change and it took a while to to get a
handle on this and I'll just do a quick
quick ammonia sidebar and one of my
tours of an ammonia plant with it these
are all old guys no gender bias here
just let's be honest about what happens
in factories of America burnt out given
the tour we're up in the kind of the
depths of the mechanical system and we
all started to smell ammonia which is
not good
and so our tour guide who owned the
system looked saw from our faces that we
something was wrong is that you guys are
smelling ammonia yeah we're smell
ammonia I worked here so long I can't
smell it anymore right so these are the
things I'm alert to in trying to go out
and make sure these systems are run
properly but but this is my favorite now
at this company we did a scorecard for
all the systems the scorecard was
ignored denied we never got the email
we've never heard of the scorecard six
months no scorecard first full year with
a scorecard 20% energy spend reduction
across the portfolio no capex so-so
coming out of that question there's this
issue of you know how do you get to know
the culture that you're dealing with so
we talked about site social skills if I
bring an engineer in I have a pattern I
want them to run if they can't naturally
run that pattern they don't get invited
back and so these are three questions
that I like in sequence and I don't like
to reveal the next question until I'm
done with the first question and they're
really simple what what has succeeded
for you guys what have you done
pull-pull-pull listen listen listen what
have you failed at you can't ask that
first you have to ask that second and
then if you do really well by the time
you ask about a wish list a lot of teams
will open up a laptop will display a
list that's really full-featured
sometimes you hear we don't we don't
really have a wish list here okay I mean
I'm gonna handle those situations very
differently but these questions it's the
same with a sales call it's like
bringing a salesperson and he he or she
doesn't ask this type of question before
they start talking it's it's a fail this
is a cry for help right this is a really
important segment of the engineering
community that has four different names
for itself is wildly underutilized right
I've never spent money for commissioning
retro-commissioning recommissioning and
I never will I pull all my engineers out
of the commissioning arena and I ask
them to go after low cost no cost energy
saving stuff right they want to come in
for two weeks and optimize for me I've
got thousands and thousands of buildings
globally I don't optimize anything I
went two days just get me the fast stuff
that's on my record of Blackstone 44%
cost out at a hospital my commissioning
engineer sat behind the BIS for two days
everything he did was tracked by the BAS
so it could be undone no comfort impact
no one noticed anything 44% and and that
we weren't even close to optimized that
that building could have gone far better
so I love commissioning engineers I'm
sorry they can't grab the 50% of the
marketplace that they deserve and and
JCI I still tell you no no don't worry
we can do our own commissioning it's not
even you guys don't get it
so this I discovered last year I had a
master class in Boston at the
Massachusetts Maritime Academy where
they trained submarine and ship
operators but they've they've gotten
smart and they they add building stuff
folks that come out of maritime are the
best site engineers the best engineers
to put in a mechanical room biomed which
is our life sciences
they only hire individuals from
Massachusetts Maritime Academy I didn't
know so a key thing about Blackstone and
I'm proud of everybody at Blackstone I
probably have just my fingertips at the
at the edge of the circle holding on
right because like the guys and women on
my team go after way more money than me
like the procurement side the healthcare
side there's a lot of big fish that
we're trying to take care of I'm a small
part of that so this thing about get
getting in line this is Jeff overly he
does Lean Six Sigma how many of you know
Lean Six Sigma the Toyota Kaizen way any
black belts anybody a black belt no
black belts so he can touch every aspect
of a mostly industrial organization and
make changes that are so far beyond what
any of us can do with our skills that
it's unbelievable
right every arm motion is a tenth of a
second you want to minimize our motions
he made somebody cry in Mexico on a
manufacturing line last year because he
takes out his Blackberry and he times
the cycle because he's looking for
bottlenecks and it's brutal and he's
really tall he's gonna deep voice to one
pair of shoes I'm terrified by this
guy's offices next to mine but he he has
the option of going in first and if I'm
lucky he'll pull me in kind of scruff of
my neck I can't and I can't be in
competition with this individual and
when I came in I tested the phrase lean
is green because it really is like he
saves tons of energy but but Lean Six
Sigma professionals don't have any time
for extra stuff like this I've never
seen him give a PowerPoint he would
never fly out here and present I assume
he makes a lot more money than me but uh
you really have to know your place and
and you don't necessarily have to fight
for your spot I spend a lot of time
making sure I understand what he's doing
so we both have videos I pulled this
this off the web and I sent it around
Blackstone he'd been viewed 120 thousand
times and you could see by the
viewership that it was global people are
really interested in Lean Six Sigma and
everybody said no no the sustainability
stuff is gonna be widely viewed I don't
even want to look at my numbers but I'm
not even close so I love this guy
I tell myself every morning so so here's
a hierarchy that's useful to me I'm
gonna run it fast with you because
you're in this space this is from simple
low value to high value and I think
you'll get this pretty quick so as a
consultant I did a lot of work for
corporations I've been paid to sit in a
room with all the big the big leadership
and talk about what does sustainability
mean for us and you craft that perfect
paragraph that can go on the website
it's sometimes it needs to be done but
in terms of transformation it's not good
for a lot green teams I shut them down
all the time so a green team usually has
no budget no authority and it's usually
too many people from different parts of
the organization and when headwinds
occur in the business the Green Teams
gone now sometimes the HR department
needs to have something in order to hire
the right people like these issues are
important but if my job is to find money
right a consensus-based Green Team with
no authority I don't want to be I'd only
be part of it number three that's where
we live I'm not going to touch this
number four all right I get to come out
and do this right I've got enough
messaging under my belt and you might
think it's all made up but I still get
invited out and I get to speak to
investors to investors I have a
particular style I know it's not it's an
acquired taste but very different than
my Blackstone colleagues that are
running spreadsheets and numbers and one
of the highest-rated presenters to
invest as a Blackstone because I I kind
of leave the reservation and stuff so
number four is important to me number
five is a surprise I mentioned I've done
two panels for Blackstone company
General Counsel's
I never thought I would do this and at
first when I was approached by our
general counsel I didn't know what he
was talking about but often the
sustainability person seemed so benign
but they've committed to annually
disclose confidential business data
around performance without talking to
general counsel that's not right and the
regulatory landscape is changing
sometimes that's great for us so it's
it's very high order to have the general
counsel aware of why I'm gonna say say
it ESG is important why there's money to
be made this type of thing okay the
biggest priority for me at Blackstone is
preventing our investors from pushing us
to do carbon footprint and I can tell
you from my experience trying to roll
out Energy Star trying to help lead
trying to change company's performance
very rapidly if I come into a deal team
CEO CFO CEO Oh general manager the
engineers that run equipment in the
basement and say look the thing we've
got to do is get our carbon footprint I
will lose tons of time I'll lose
credibility it's not a KPI people don't
know what this is you got to spend extra
money to bring in an expert and I sorry
to cause any friction here and maybe the
questions over reveal you don't like
this it's a profanity if your job is
finding performance improvement and
proving that it's valuable to the bottom
line at a company if you take this side
trip you will endanger your career my
opinion that was harsh I'm sorry I was
seen that seemed very rough sorry Anna
voluntary market transformation this is
the phrase we used to use when we were
developing the Energy Star programs
right it's what lead is it's what Grzyb
is I love this concept right I don't
have a budget all right I don't have any
authority right if I if I don't pay
attention to voluntary market
transformation concepts that make people
want to play money and I don't I don't
get to keep my job
mandatory disclosure this is new I
remember when lead hated this concept
because lead was excellence so if you
start to make it mandatory that's go to
jail don't go to jail it's not a very
fun line to work at but this is very
helpful to me right
with the general counsel involved I can
go and say every year it's more cities
and there's penalties and our data is
inaccurate which means I can't show
benefit over time this is pretty good so
now I'm going to go through a few what I
think are classic
surprising things that have happened to
me over the years and hopefully a lot
you'll have some place to put this stuff
peat at cleaning all right we own tons
and tons of limited servers hotels right
LaQuinta extended stay motel six
Hilton's got a bunch of them brief
select they have peat taxis of these
boxes under the windows I call them
boxes they're just they're cheap they're
noisy they don't last long it's hard to
manage tens of thousands of these in a
fleet are really hard to manage so we
get them clean because you can watch the
nicotine stains right get steam cleaned
off in the parking lot 25 bucks you can
hire a team that'll haul it to the
parking lot steam clean it they know
where not to steam clean because you'll
ruin the unit if you don't do it
carefully it's low margin work I knew
there were energy savings nobody in the
marketplace could tell me
so it's blacks don't worry I have a
large portfolio so we did before after
it's 8% so now I can talk about return
on investment I wasn't able to do that
before so no charge for that Pete at
Controls Motel six came into the
Blackstone portfolio they said they made
a change they were kind of proud of it
within the PTAC units there's dip
switches that you can adjust to change
the range of the hot/cold knob and
you know limited services family comes
in oh it's hot so they pay get cold then
they go out to dinner and then they go
to sleep or they leave or they pay get
hot comes from the factory sixty to
eighty five degrees but that's a pretty
broad spread so motel six said we're
going 65 to 80 okay so I did summits
with all of our hospitality we taught
everybody this motel sixes materials
training their site crews to change the
dip switches were shared that was a four
million dollar a year savings move
across Blackstone portfolio for this so
and and I never heard of it before
toilet flapper I brought one this is how
endanger my career cuz I'm sixty one
okay this is a universal toilet flapper
it fits any toilet so one of my
hospitality company said we found this
flapper we can use it everywhere our
site engineers can trim it in case it
you know it needs to be trimmed to fit I
said that sounds wrong it doesn't sound
right to me so I said you got data
before ya got data after give you the
data the penalty for using a universal
flapper eighteen percent 18 percent
water consumption toilets are designed
so that the flapper stays up for just
the right amount of time to go with the
suction cycle right if it's too soon
you're out of luck on your flush if it's
too late you're out of luck on your
flush and you've got a flush again this
is tough stuff what during a dinner
presentation last night it was right
before dessert I got this I got this out
so California installed a million
low-flow toilets right in there's a big
water problem we did a uh we did a
webinar for a quarter million hotel
rooms in California we just went through
all this stuff they saw their savings
and then they saw their savings a road
so they did a study in the 90s and what
they found is the maintenance teams when
it's time for new flapper they got the
hardware store and they buy a universal
flower so I have a team and at one point
they had a full-time employee dedicated
to black stone it's WMI out of Northern
Virginia they went site to site they
confiscated the incorrect flappers
they restock the attic stock they label
the stock killer now if you go out to
the marketplace this is important and
say I want to say I want to save some
water say will sell you new toilets I
don't think so
infrared camera this is part of a
toolkit that I have twenty-four thousand
dollar toolkit for industrials four
thousand dollar toolkit for commercial
real estate infrared cameras now the
size of a cell phone cost 200 bucks to
put a module onto an iPhone when I
started my career as fifty thousand
dollars for an infrared cameras the size
of a baby and individuals would buy one
and their business was hire a helicopter
or scan your roof come into your factory
scan your electrical circuits a lot of
companies that I encounter say yeah we
know infrared cameras we have a
consultant comes in once a year well now
that they're 200 bucks I want this on
the hip of every operator because you
can find steam leaks insulation issues
bad motor bearings it's it's like magic
and the the kits that I have are full of
this stuff fully under utilized one of
my one of my companies pointed out to me
that I have over a million dollars worth
of tool kits out I'm really happy about
that but it's not the tool kits although
operators are excited to have toys
sometimes they say we already know about
these so it's a great can I see what
you've got the drawer gets open it's
dusty the battery's dead right it's PMS
all right you've got to establish
prevent a maintenance task so they have
somebody's name associated with them and
then the tools get used this is a
handheld laser temperature gun at one of
my resorts the security team used this
at night to fill in a table of
temperatures to hand to the engineering
team the next morning just to see what
was happening at night which is
brilliant and when I do hospitality we
do night walks at 3 a.m. that's where
you see all the stuff that you're not
supposed to see but I asked the head of
security any of your team have a problem
with this said well one of my team came
to me and said this is a really security
work
nice and I said to him it is job
security work so there's there's always
jokes you can always find the judge if
you're open to them I think this is I
think there's my last one of these I was
in a factory trying to get them to buy
into the use of an air knife which is a
engineered compressed air blower and
they needed it to blow water off of
their product after it came out of a
cooling tank and these were sorry to
stereotype but these were a lot of old
individuals that worked in this factory
forever
they've been blowing water off product
for a long time if you don't blow the
water off the product thoroughly it's
it's scrapped and defect so we got on
the phone with a company that made the
air knife and the maintenance team had
already decided if they could get one
they could reverse engineer it and then
build their own in the in their shop
which is a really bad idea I mean it's
an engineered piece of blower technology
so at that I said look this is what's
gonna happen I'm coming in over the
weekend and we're just gonna go in your
shop and we're gonna build all kinds of
stuff
because we can and we love it but we're
not gonna try and reverse engineer
things that have been designed by real
to compress their blower engineers
anyway so that was a law awkward but on
the phone call the the woman who was
running the call from the manufacturer
said what is the water quality spec that
you use in your coin tanks and you just
it's great to look around the table and
everybody's just like slack-jawed and I
just said just to be just to be clear
none of you have ever talked about water
quality specs I don't know this stuff no
we've never heard of this so this is the
spec that causes water to beat up so it
can be blown off a product so from an
energy perspective we can get really
excited and say great energy savings
associated with compressed air
unbelievable but if you can take it one
step further and this gets to my theme
of being tied in at a broader level the
scrap and defect benefits here are gonna
blow the energy savings out of the water
so it wasn't no pun but
you have to take the time to find where
the greatest value is so you can sell
your deal so this was surprising to me
and it's this kind of stuff I like so
here's my current best success story 100
year old global manufacturer I had three
years I was able to hire the right
person 60 million dollar per year base
spend they didn't give us capex we saved
25% of that 60 million dollars and if
you wanted to talk about emissions you
could now weave IP owed when the new
shareholders come at them they have a
story that they can tell and so this
this is something I'm very proud of
here's something I'm not so proud of I
think I already told a 44 percent story
this was a hospital portfolio in the
u.s. it took us a long time for them to
let us come into one site and see what
we could do we found 44% two days at the
same time they said look this is a like
the red balloon we have a LEED certified
site you're really gonna like that why
don't you go look at that because it's
fantastic you'll see how good we are do
you mind if we do an Energy Star
benchmark no no we don't mind so that
allowed me to go to this team and say
you're LEED certified Hospital is among
the worst performing hospitals in the US
what what are you talking about now
turned out the individuals that I had
been paired with were designed and
construction they didn't care this this
was not their money so I came to the
table of something I was very excited
about and I watched a number of people
be completely unmoved and then one
Monday morning it was a NASA we'd sold
them they were off my list so new stuff
I remember when simulation was done with
punch cards you had to wait overnight
and then we had desktops and it took
three hours and you set your alarm so
you could get up and see if your
simulation was correct and then it was
30 seconds and you could just run
simulation after simulation do
parametric analysis I haven't done
anything like that in 25 years and I
don't know what's happening in that
space but at the time that's where I
developed a lot of intuition
about how buildings work but now we have
Internet of Things machine learning
artificial intelligence the cloud these
phrases don't mean a lot to me at my age
however I do know that I can get remote
visibility into performance and I can
find things from far away but the guys
on site can't find and I think things to
watch out for software-as-a-service is
really big it makes all buy deal guys
perk up energy as a service you'll be
hearing about this I don't I don't care
for it because I think it's and we've
had people come in pitches on LEDs as a
service it's ridiculous
but be as a service thing it's not going
away and this is my last slide so I had
a CEO come at me in a conference with a
whole bunch of CEOs and said Don talks
about energy and we love him but it's
not why we love him it's because he
helps us with our productivity the
predictability of our platform which we
need to to grow the business if machines
are run better and they're more
predictable people don't get hurt so the
Health and Safety person is always a fan
and when you pull out the toolkit and go
look for leaks and the gas system always
bring the health and safety person
that's because I have a this is a secret
you always find leaks and they always
freak out which is good and then M&A we
grow companies through M&A if you have a
scorecard takes you about 20 minutes to
let the new company know what the rules
of play are around the stuff we care for
and that's that's nice because sometimes
you'll have cultural friction around
operations for years and you just can't
get a hold of it
scorecard and that's it that's what I
have and I think we're gonna do
questions I'll answer anything
Thank You Don we we do have time for a
few questions if anyone has questions
some of you might have come in later in
the day there's an app that we're using
the information is on a sheet of paper
in the middle of your table for a
specific question you just type in sly
TOCOM and then you put in the code for
CMU energy and we had the questions for
you I'm actually gonna start with Vivian
because she has a question so I can't
imagine that Blackstone is the only
company that has done portfolio wide
interventions the way you've talked
about can you talk about other companies
that are doing this you've been working
with Schneider Electric I know as a
company they've done a lot of portfolio
management what's your sense of the of
the market place it's good it's a good
question I think since I started working
at Blackstone I don't I don't get out
much now when we were doing energy star
work I would put together a table
because you could find this on the web
of companies that advertised that
communicated notable reductions of
portfolio energy usage so there's lots
of good examples and sometimes I prepare
a list for the success the sector I'm
working working with but I think to go
out and get services around portfolio
performance improvement it's really hard
to do it I wish I had a better answer
Schneider
I love Schneider 25 of my companies use
Schneider for procurement the
procurement savings in deregulated
markets globally will pay for the entire
service because we use them so much my
scorecard my dashboard the resource
advisor tool is free and having done
Energy Star portfolio manager you know
over the years I know what I want in a
in kind of a dashboarding tool but I
don't let their engineers in into my
buildings and so I met with the CEO of
the shop that serves us and he said Don
I got a hundred engineers and you never
use any of them I said look I've met all
100 of your engineers right in order in
order to put kids through college and
this is an expensive school you you have
to sell big projects so the whole ESCO
marketplace it wants to finance
equipment right and replace everything
I don't want to replace anything so for
me the best the best thing I can tell
you is find a commissioning engineer
that you can control don't ask for
commissioning and then try and get a
score card that matches the systems you
have in place that leadership will buy
into and it's it's it's different I
don't think there's a lot of people
making money doing this stuff I don't
mean to be cranky but I just ended up
here somehow just quickly is there a
future for portfolio manager that's a
good question I for those in this space
if you didn't go find the press on
Trump's scores that were pulled from the
publicly disclosed databases it's pretty
interesting it it it's it's interesting
I think it's the best thing that Energy
Star has and I'm on GBC eye board I know
I don't want to say what my opinions are
but the problem with dedicating your
portfolio to a government funded 20 year
old asset is that there's some risk
there and I might want more flexibility
I hope so I respect all the effort that
went into that and I still know the
people at energy store I'm sure you do
too Anna but Internet of Things machine
learning you know now you can buy a
fleet of thermostats and you can program
them all remotely so that they stay
program the way you want
I don't think Energy Star as the budget
or the culture to keep up with what's
happening next that's one way to say so
two questions one is as someone says
what would you say to a student who
wants to do the kind of work that you do
and the other is what would you tell
your 20 year old self now that would
help kind of move this along more
quickly well this is horrible
if I could show a picture of my 20 hero
himself you would immediately see that
he wasn't listening
so my 50s where I'm gonna do the second
question first my 50s were my best
decade and I took me a lot of work to
learn how to get along with people
better and play against a at all scary
Lean Six Sigma guy as my partner instead
of somebody that I was trying to run in
front of or take space from so for me I
had kind of deeper emotional
intelligence issues that I probably
would help myself with some of that well
that's too revealing
this is not that being filmed is it in
terms of people that are out trying to
get educated around this stuff my
master's degrees in solar technology
back when it was water
not not electricity so that hasn't been
a lot of use to me I think you're gonna
learn a lot of stuff on the job I wish I
had gotten an engineering undergraduate
degree but at the same time I think a
broad-based education is really
important so a little bit of Finance the
ability to work with numbers the ability
to communicate I grew up shy it's it
this is it was not a comfortable event
for me you know thirty years ago but I
think a lot of the challenge for energy
efficiency professionals is how to come
into a culture and take advantage of
some assets that are in the culture be
patient and be nimble and work toward
changing the culture that's not in my
mind that's not the first thing you're
going to take from an engineering school
so if you come out with a hardcore
engineering degree and you just want to
work with mechanical systems you're
you're soon enough gonna run into people
that aren't gonna let you hang around
unless you can prove to them that
there's valued at a company and that
there's money and there's a reputational
benefit there's a lot of sideshow stuff
that needs to be negotiated that's worth
it's worth having what most of you may
not agree with what I said today but I
have an opinion that helps me stay in my
job you need to know enough about the
landscape to have an opinion is that it
useful at all did I dance around them
too much so two questions related to the
price of carbon
how would your private equity colleagues
respond to a market where with a wide
price with a price on carbon and would
you care more about carbon if there were
a price on it oh I really really hate
carbon so it's gonna take me a lot of
commitment talk to you about this
instead give my experience when I was a
sustainability consultant for
corporations we would get called in
occasionally this was before the
downturn like companies who would say
we're ready to start doing some carbon
trading it looks pretty good to us so my
first question would be how's your data
what are you talking about okay if we're
gonna have that that landscape to play
on you need you need really good data
and it starts with what I care about
which is utilities spend visibility
right that's gonna be a first step and
frankly for the 25 companies that I use
Snyder for there's a button it's a
carbon button and I'm sure what gets
spit out is very good because their
dominant global energy procurement
entity so they've got good emissions
factors I have never heard carbon or the
price of carbon mentioned by any of my
Blackstone colleagues in seven years
right and we we are aware that we buy
generating assets in Texas for pennies
on the dollar that might make some of
you unhappy but I have a case study on
how we invest in them and make them more
efficient
they pollute less they generate more so
we fix them they exist they're running
we make them run better but I can't I
can't answer that question because it's
not a conversation I've ever heard or
been invited into or want to be part of
that was harsh
so Blackstone bought a local wind
companies turbines recently why so we
get pressure to do impact investing
right so that to me signals that we're
going to take a pot of money draw a
circle around it and accept lesser
returns instead we have three solar
companies we did
Buju Gally hydro in Uganda we've done a
lot of stuff with windmere wind was a
german investment
we we do this because we can make money
on it that's it right our our
responsibility is to our investors and
their responsibilities to mostly pension
pension funds we exist to find money for
our investors it's really simple it's
the right thing to do but we did it to
make money so let's see lots of
questions coming in I'm sorry I'm not
going to be able to get all of these so
what would you do differently if your
performance was judged on ten year
returns rather than three that's good
probably nothing right I I really
believe that onm gets you to low cost no
cost and then I can walk into any
portfolio and get 15 to 25 percent if I
can get leadership to listen for me
that's a much better endeavor than
trying to bring an ESCO in and figure
out how much new stuff we want to buy I
don't do technology plays or I I know
that they they are available and they
works I mean sometimes I get to capex I
would do nothing different and Obama's
chief sustainability officer Kate brand
invited me down to speak to 25 chief
sustainability officers of the federal
to federal agencies they're trapped by
ESPC super ESPC right they there they
are trapped in the ESCO world and so
they liked low cost no cost on them but
they said we don't we don't have a way
to get to this but if I had a different
career and I work for an ESCO I would
want to get that 20% for nothing to make
my investment in technology look better
so how do you feel about the new concept
of a person a Purpose Driven economy Wow
Wow
so these are real questions III I know
they're real I grew up in the late 60s
early 70s right the fact that I'm
standing here in a suit when I work for
Blackstone is shocking to me I would
never have predicted this in a million
years to me Purpose Driven economy this
is this is it right we we found a way to
make performance improvement the global
I have $100,000,000 target on my back my
two analysts it there's a lot of money
involved in performance improvement so
that's that's Purpose Driven economy
last question no do you want more we go
to the top of the hour especially
they're they're so challenging so what
do you think the most important thing
universities like Carnegie Mellon can do
not only to reduce their carbon
footprint which was the question but
just generally speaking okay in the
mechanical space it could be mechanical
or research so I think I think what
would be really great is if everybody
that's in an energy efficiency program
were involved in running the campus
score carding system and cadence calls
and meetings with the operators and you
are forced to do it in a friendly way so
when they see you coming
there's they're psyched to see you
coming I think that's a that's a degree
of exposure that's really important I
think sometimes this is like a small
echo chamber the academic community and
trying to trying to get out and see how
other businesses I'm happy I got invited
to speak you you've got to go look at
stuff it's not going well and look at a
nice thing about my job is I get to see
25 different corporate cultures every
year and they're really different and
they they will kill your strategy
exposure
real mechanical rooms real
decision-makers so then the last
question okay it's as based on your
great talk I can't believe you like the
word sustainability why aren't you just
called the energy cost savings guy see I
spent so much time dog in carbon I'm
really proud of my chief sustainability
officer title my boss is Dave Calhoun he
came from GE Jack Welsh his protege and
there's some talk that if he hadn't left
GE to come work for a Blackstone company
Nielsen the ratings system GE wouldn't
be in such trouble now but he's my new
boss I didn't I thought I was too old to
have a new boss and then here comes Dave
Calhoun he's he's he's formidable when I
first met him the first thing he said
was I don't like your title because
sustainability is a confusing word so
when I go out to companies and I do my
job I never use the word sustainability
I just don't use it I I asked about
spend spend visibility if we can find
20% savings off of this spend is is it
excited enough to decide enough to do
something and in some cases I'll say
look if I hire someone to go after this
money they will find 10 times what you
pay them that's usually true that's
that's the nature of my first
conversation oh that's a good that's a
good question
with that I think we should give dawn
[Applause]